[Music]
[Applause]
let me give the official introduction to
uh john oates rock and roll
r b soul guitar singer songwriter record
producer rock and roll hall of famer and
of course one half of uh haulin oates i
mentioned that uh holo notes have uh
made 21 albums they've sold over 80
million albums and uh making them the
most successful duo in rock history 10
number one records over 20 top 40 hits
and john oates joining us on the program
john thanks for joining us let me
apologize before we start this for
whatever is going to happen after this
but uh it's great to have you on great
to see you again
it's great to see you too dan thanks man
uh i just i just finished the tour so uh
man it's uh it's it's great to be here
in our cabin in colorado and i'm gonna
get a little bit of r and r before we
resume but um anyway it's great to talk
to you and whenever i go to paris and
i'm having breakfast i have i have
breakfast with john yes oh of course
but of course now i knew you i knew you
but i didn't know if you knew me that's
when i thought well i'm just gonna walk
over and say hello now
you can be honest
i took i took the croissant out of my
mouth and i was uh no no of course i
know you you know i'm a sports fan i've
i follow you and watch your show and
um yeah it was great i mean it's always
great to see a fellow
yank in when you're in a foreign country
and uh
you know it reminds me of the good old
days man when we just traveled around
and uh
enjoyed being in europe so uh things
have changed but yeah that was a that
was a good time all right your favorite
band or artist that you performed with
over the years is
who wow wow that's a heck of a question
you know we performed
i don't know where it is to begin we
perform you know we open for stevie
wonder we opened for david bowie on his
first american tour blood sweat and
tears we played with uh you know we've
played with when we've done shows with
the eagles and the list goes on i mean
we've been doing this for almost 50
years so but both
bowie wasn't ziggy stardust this was yes
it was his first it was the first show
on the ziggy stardust tour and we opened
for him in memphis tennessee absolutely
what did you think when you saw
i was shocked because i had been a fan
of him for his first album hunky dory
which he was which was kind of an
experimental singer-songwriter acoustic
kind of record and i had no idea what he
was going to do and when he came out in
the sequin you know
with the red hair and the whole bit i
was like okay so you can actually do
that in your career
it was eye-opening honestly but
then you're with stevie wonder
the list goes on and on you know we you
know we did live aid in philly with mick
jagger and tina turner and we played the
apollo theater with eddie kendrick and
david ruffin from the temptations i mean
i really you know um we've just been
blessed and fortunate to be part of a
great era in in rock music history and
uh you know i feel like we got a chance
to pick the cherries from the top of the
tree you know
but would you rather talk music or would
you rather talk sports
i'll talk sports we're a sports joe man
i i love sports i'm i've been a you know
i'm
an amateur athlete i guess you could say
over the years when i was in school and
uh
always loved always loved football but i
was always too small to play and um well
i was
in junior high i wasn't too small until
i kept getting my butt kicked and then i
said i better better concentrate on
strumming my guitar okay you get a
chance to meet nick saban
oh
yes what was that like
we were playing in tuscaloosa and the
promoter was a an alabama alum and we
had it was right he said he said to me
he goes hey after soundcheck do you want
to go over and see alabama practice i
said yes
yes
and i get got a bunch of the guys in the
band together we went over there and it
was it was an amazing experience i have
to say if if you ever have to question
about why alabama is alabama
just if you had the
good fortune to take a tour of their
facility
and see what happens inside that room
it's it you know you'll become a
believer immediately and
it was really interesting because we
actually got to meet coach saban and
they told us when we first came in that
he very rarely sees anyone during during
the season
and um so we were saying well you know
sure of course whatever you know
whatever he says but we went up to his
uh office and uh he has a nice nice
woman who kind of handles uh things for
him up there and i said any chance i
could sit at his desk
and she said sure i said can i wear his
hat
and she says yeah i said what about can
i put the rings on
and she said absolutely because he had
all his rings on the front desk there's
a picture of me i'll send it to you
there's a picture of me sitting at his
desk with the hat and going like this
and we got all the rings on and it was
amazing and then in the next room he was
sitting there doing some paperwork and
he graciously got up and spent uh spent
a good five ten minutes with us and uh
we talked but i could tell his mind was
somewhere else even though he was
you know he was very very cordial with
us but he he was he was focused and and
it was an amazing experience so i have
to say we saw you know jaylen hurts and
and tua were both practicing with two
different groups at the same time it was
during that period of time and uh it was
great it was amazing but when i first
met you in paris
and you said you loved the scc like how
did you fall in love with sec football i
moved to nashville
i i i had to uh i had i had no choice
um you know you you live in the south
you uh you eats uh sleep and drink sec
and it's you know and quite frankly you
know it's it's just an amazingly
competitive and
uh very high level of excitement and the
fans it's a culture it's a culture in
the south it's more than just a football
game
have you guys done the anthem at a
sporting event i've done the anthem a
number of times i did the anthem um i in
fact we just played denver just two
nights ago at at the former pepsi center
and i first time i did the anthem was
for a nuggets game but the most
memorable one was when i did the anthem
for um the phillies against the rays
on the famous game that got rained out
the only game i think in world series
history that got rained out and winded
out i mean i remember people they were
hitting uh fly balls and
the ball was landing like 30 feet from
the you know uh so like i got to sing
that sing it there and uh i've sung it a
number of times
um
and then you guys just got off a tour
you were traveling around the world and
then you're coming back stateside and
then you'll start hearing
no no just do due to covid we we had you
know obviously we were off for a year
and a half we just did a 12 12 cities
and um we started august 5th uh quite
frankly i wasn't sure whether we were
going to make it to today um if if our
tour manager called me in the morning
and said hey dude go home it wouldn't
have surprised me but the fans turned
out the the audience was incredible we
we had a very secure covered safe bubble
uh among our our team and our crew
no one got sick so you know i counted as
a big win and we just finished that and
we'll resume on september 18th we start
in maryland we go down south and we end
up at the hollywood bowl on october 1st
who was your favorite band growing up
wow um well i'm i'm going to show my age
but you know
i go back to the early days of rock and
roll chuck berry and elvis little
richard and then up through the 60s the
great r b that came out of uh stacks
vault you know sam and dave otis redding
curtis mayfield from chicago the
temptations uh a lot of the great philly
artists as well so you know it's been a
mixed bag i love singer songwriters joni
mitchell i was a big fan of the band so
i have a really eclectic taste when it
comes to music but you guys don't refer
to yourself as holo notes
well
i mean isn't it every album like it's
daryl hall and john oates we did that on
purpose so i know it seems like a subtle
point but uh we always wanted to be
perceived as two guys who work together
and it's it's i know it's a subtle
distinction but it matters to us and so
the world calls us whole notes it's more
convenient of course
but yeah we're two individuals we think
differently uh we lead different lives
uh we come together and we have a lot of
commonality where our music comes
together but um we're perfectly capable
making records and doing things
individually
all right um fritzy who booked you is a
huge whole notes fan i i kind of heard
uh the preamble to this okay all right
you know where i'm going with this john
i'm not quite sure but i think i'm ready
okay
fritzy what song would you like to sing
i'm going to say to john
not with john if john decides that he
wants to uh join in but um
i i'm assuming that's water you're
taking a drink out of john before you do
this not not vodka or anything well you
know yeah actually it is it is water but
i have a feeling i have a feeling i'm
going to wish it
[Laughter]
all right fritzy what what do you want
to sing
with one of your idols i chose kiss on
my list private eyes probably my
favorite but i went with kiss on my list
okay why don't you sing just a little
bit so john at least understands sort of
you know what what your voice range is
hopefully you won't kill me too much
because again since i'm a little kid i
love all notes i'm you know i don't want
to say president of the fan club but i'm
a huge fan just sing okay okay my
friends wonder why i call you all the
time what can i say
i don't feel the need to give such
secrets away
you think maybe i need help no way
that's enough okay that's enough all
right
i get it i've heard that song before no
that's you know what that's pretty darn
good thanks i have to say i'm gonna tell
daryl that you
yeah yeah yeah you're ready you're ready
to step in at any moment yeah i'm sure
daryl's going to go huh
yeah yeah okay so that was just a
sampling here that was very exciting
just now
that was you seriously made a dream come
true here that i'm talking to john oates
and singing now see once again i mean
no when i make my dreams i'm not seeing
i know i'm able to play on words with
one of the songs but i'm genuinely being
serious right now that you know john
oates on the show and me uh singing
along with him i just it's crazy right
now john do people come up and and use
those lines to you
like that the song titles yes yeah they
you know women will come up and go hey
i'm a man-eater and i go
i'm sorry for you
i really feel sorry for you um you know
it's
you know what i've realized while i was
listening to you guys uh prior to coming
on i realized that our song titles can
could actually
be part of a conversation
um
it's it's kind of interesting you you
guys were like throwing out all these
titles and a lot of deep tracks too
which was cool because you've got uh
family man i can't go for that uh kiss
on my list man-eater uh one-on-one out
of touch private eyes rich girl sarah
smile say it ain't so she's gone uh you
make my dreams uh you've you've lost
that loving feeling
mm-hmm yeah um
pritzy do you have another one that you
want to do here with john before i put
him you know out of his misery and i let
him go okay i chose you've lost that
loving feeling because that's that's
like all john oates he he gets that
rolling and that's like all about oats
so i thought that would be a good song
are you is that your song though that's
no no no that was written by phil by uh
barry mann and cynthia weil two amazing
brill building songwriters from way back
in new york city uh that was originally
recorded by the righteous brothers
and um that's like i mean if you have a
minute i can tell you a very kind of
quick crazy story about that yes
absolutely we had made an album called
voices in the early 80s and um in those
days what we would do is we would have a
listening party for our friends for the
record company radio people and we'd
bring them into the studio and we
debuted the album you know and of course
it would always hopefully uh you know a
big success we did that and uh you know
everyone was the vibe was good but we
felt daryl and i both felt after we
listened to it in its entirety we said
something's missing we didn't know what
it was so after the listening party we
were in the village we were recording an
electric lady on 8th street in greenwich
village and we went to the pizza place
which was literally a half a block down
the street and we were having some pizza
and on the jukebox came the righteous
brothers original version of you lost
that love and feeling and we looked at
each other go why don't we just cut that
and so the next morning we went into the
studio with a band we cut it in half a
day
recorded the track sang the song put it
on the album and it became a big hit for
us so it was just one of those things it
was just kind of happened
but and you were also we are the world
you you're part of that
right i mean there were a lot of
different people in there but you know
how do you explain that though i mean
you you had
was wayland jennings there
i i i'm not sure
dan aykroyd
no
no
no there were only the only musical
performers in the room are you sure
well he might have been there i i you
know what there was so much going on it
was so
heady to be in that room all i know is
where i was standing where they placed
me in the group
ray charles was off my left shoulder
bob dylan was off my right shoulder and
all i knew is that i was in a really
good place i said this is cool i said i
don't know what's happening here but i
feel good about where i'm at right now
all right fritzy are you ready
yes okay john you can choose two
jump in or you can just sit there and
listen i don't know i may have to just
enjoy this but let's see where okay i i
okay
you never close your eyes
anymore when i kiss
your lips that's the way all right
there's no tenderness life before in
your fingertips
you're trying hard not to show it
but baby
baby i know
it
okay okay you know what okay you get the
part you got the part okay when they do
when they do my bio pic i'll make sure
that we
uh we call you
first uh john you're a good sport and uh
once again it was great seeing you uh
when we had breakfast in paris uh good
luck with the tour and and uh i know
you're part of our celebrity bracket
challenge with march madness we hope to
have you back again yeah absolutely
thank you can't wait this weekend's
college football first weekend i'm i'm
excited thank you bud
all right uh
john oates hall of famer all right todd
that was just beyond incredible there
you go i'm so happy i just make dreams
come true you really do how cool is that
i'm just so excited